Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain the American science fiction film
called “Voyagers.” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
The movie starts in the year 2063 AD. Human
existence is at risk of extinction because of
climate change, decreasing biodiversity, and
decreasing supply of clean drinking water.
The deteriorating situation of the earth has been
troubling scientists for a long time. In such
harsh conditions, they work hard to find a planet
where humans can settle upon. At the beginning of
the movie, the top scientists and astronomers
of the world are in a conference meeting.
They have finally found an Earth-like exoplanet
far away in the galaxy and discuss how they can
colonize it. An astrophysicist who is presenting
the idea says that they will have to leave for the
exoplanet as soon as possible because the voyage
will take eighty-six years. Thus, the crew will
have to reproduce on board and only the third
generation of humans who board the ship will make
it to the exoplanet. The scientists’ first problem
is to find thirty qualified crew members who are
willing to leave everyone they know on earth to
spend the rest of their lives on a spaceship.
Moreover, they have to ensure that no one feels
the stress of prolonged confinement because then,
they would want to return to the earth. The only
solution to this problem is to breed their own
crew members and train them in isolation. That
way, the crew members wouldn’t know how the
earth was and wouldn’t feel nostalgic. So, the
scientists use bioengineering to give birth to
thirty babies who will in the future initiate the
eighty-six years-long voyage to the exoplanet. The
kids are raised and trained by a scientist named
Richard Alling. Richard treats the kids as his
own and with time, grows attached to them. After
a few years, he insists on joining them on their
trip to space. His colleague warns that he will
never be able to return but Richard is adamant
about the decision. Eventually, when the kids
are of a certain age, they fly to outer space
with Richard as their guardian. The ship will
be their home for the rest of their lives.
Cut to some years later. The kids have grown
into youngsters and are perfectly accustomed to
their lives in space. They wake up every day at
the same time and take educational classes that
tell them of their purpose. Then, they exercise
and do a regular mechanical check. After that,
they eat together in the cafeteria. Throughout
all this, the crew seems void of human emotions
as they do not chat with each other
often. An important part of their day
is taking a blue liquid after every meal.
In the following scene, we see two crew members
named Chris and Zach listening to classical
music as a recreational activity. Another
member named Cela is having doubts about the
mission and thinks of her life as unimportant.
So, she talks to Richard about it. Richard
calmly explains that they are the most
important humans in history. He reveals he has
been feeling lonely for a long time and shows
Cela pictures of his family from the earth.
The crew grows its own plant to sustain life for
the years they will be on the ship. One day, Chris
discovers that there is a toxin named T56J in the
water they irrigate the plants with. The water
is filtered urine which means that the toxin is
coming from the crew’s body. He asks Richard about
the toxin but he simply tells Chris to change the
filtration system. Later, Chris does some research
on the toxin but finds no information about it
in the database. He even tells Zac about the
matter. After everyone is asleep at night, the two
hack into the database and find out that the toxin
comes from the blue liquid they drink every day.
They also reveal that the toxin makes humans
docile, eliminates sexual desires, and decreases
pleasure response. That means the crew is
being drugged so they can be kept in check.
From the following day, Zac and Chris stop
taking the blue liquid. They also tell two
of the other crew members named Kai and
Julie about the discovery. Moreover,
Chris has also found an unmarked compartment
in the ship behind the walls. The four of them
have begun to doubt their creators. During
a routine conversation with Richard, Chris
tells him that he has discovered an unidentified
chamber in the blueprints, and demands to know
its purpose and what exactly is inside of it.
Richard proceeds to evasively tell him that such
information is classified and that the chamber is
reserved for the third generation on board.
The following day, Chris and Zac go through the
emotions they have never felt in their lives
before. Being off the blue liquid is like being on
drugs for them. Zach feels sexually attracted to
Sela and grabs her arm. He lets go of her only
after Richard casually tells him to maintain
distance. During their workout, Zac and Chris
play fight, feeling the rush of adrenaline for
the first time. Sometime later, the two are in
the hallways when they hear strange noises from
the ship’s ceiling. They go to the control room
and ask crewmate Edward about it. Richard has told
them that it is just the noise of the ship’s parts
contracting. But Edward believes that the noise
is caused by some extraterrestrial creature.
After a while, Richard holds an emergency meeting
informing the crew that they have lost contact
with the earth because of some LCT malfunction.
They will have to repair the transmitter from
the outside of the ship. Richard asks Zac to
join him and assigns everyone their respective
roles. As they prepare, Zac starts touching Sela
inappropriately. A surprised Richard stops him and
asks Sela if she is fine. Zac runs away from them
and Richard goes behind him. A girl named
Phoebe informs Richard that Zac has stopped
taking the blue liquid. Richard then meets Chris
who reveals that he hasn’t been taking it either.
The two decide to complete the reparation first
then talk about the matter. They get into their
spacesuits and go outside. Meanwhile, Kai from
the navigation room helps them as the others
are in the control room doing the same. Kai is
soon joined by Zac. All of a sudden, Richard’s
suit malfunctions and electrocutes him. At the
same time, the whole ship malfunctions making
the crew panic. The systems room catches on fire
while every technical difficulty arises at the
same time. The crew set the fire out while Chris
somehow manages to get Richard inside the ship.
They hurriedly take him to the medbay and use
a defibrillator on him. However, it doesn’t
work and Richard dies. Sela, being the chief
medical professional, sadly announces him dead.
After everything calms down, the crew surrounds
Richard’s body and discusses what went wrong.
Edward says that he saw something dark pull
Richard right before his death. He thinks
it was an alien. Chris assures everyone that it
was outside the ship so they should be fine. Zac
volunteers to be the new chief officer replacing
Richard but everyone else decides they should
vote. The voting takes place and eventually Chris
is elected as the chief officer. He then orders
everyone to repair the damage that was caused to
the ship as soon as possible. The crew gets to
work and Sela goes to Richard’s room to get rid
of his belongings as per the protocol. However,
she begins to watch pictures and videos
of his family and decides to keep them.
Christopher joins her and the two watch the
video documentary that Richard had made.
In the video, he says that he came to the mission
because he wanted to protect the kids. The two are
confused as to what they need protection from but
little do they know what is about to happen next.
A while later, Chris goes to check on the crew’s
progress and sees no one around. He finds everyone
in the plantation area trying to fix the food
storage. Zac had brought them there saying that
food should be their first priority and they
shouldn’t let it go bad. Chris agrees and lets
them do what they want. After dinner that day, Kai
tells everyone not to drink the blue liquid. The
following day, the crew feels various emotions
at the same time that they cannot control.
Their anger and desires are heightened.
Zac and Julie touch each other, feeling attracted
to the opposite sex for the first time. Others
fight, run around the ship and ignore all their
duties. One day, they get into Richard’s room
and watch films in his collection. From those,
they find out about violence, guns, and sexual
intercourse. Sela finds them in the room and
orders them to get out as the chief medical
officer. On his way out, Zac threatens Sela,
asking her to be careful because Richard isn't
there to protect her anymore. Later that day,
Chris sees Kai and Julie having intercourse in
the exercise room. He also notices Zac looking
for Sela and runs to her before he can. He
hugs her to show Zac she is already busy.
At the same time, Kai finds a guy named Peter
and Julie getting close. Enraged with jealousy,
he attacks Peter, making him run away. Later,
everyone is at the cafeteria when Peter hits
Kai with a metal tool to take revenge. Chris
and the others separate the fight and schedule
an emergency meeting in the control room. In the
meeting, Chris puts forward his dissatisfaction
regarding the crew’s performance but Zac
interrupts him frequently. Edward says that he
doesn’t want to work in the control room anymore
because he thinks it has aliens brought by Richard
when he last space walked. This scares everyone
as they too have been hearing the noises. Taking
this opportunity, Zac says that he will save the
crew from the aliens and provide them with a lot
of food. He also declares that he is forming a
separate group from Chris and people on his side
can follow him. Half of the crew leaves with
Zac while the other half stays with Chris.
Chris’s group is also worried that the alien might
be real so they go to collect the surveillance
footage from the systems room. After they leave,
Zac’s team arrives there and Kai and he go inside.
They act like an alien attacked them in the room
to scare their group and keep them submissive.
Meanwhile, Chris and the group watch the
surveillance footage and find a clip of Zac
and Kai deliberately electrocuting Richard. They
are beyond surprised when they find that the two
killed Richard. The following morning, they are
woken up by a knock on the door. Zac and his group
are there to invite them for lunch. Chris and the
team carefully come to the cafeteria and start to
eat. Just then, Zac walks in front of everyone
and declares himself the new chief officer.
But Chris retaliates and shows everyone the clip
of Zac and Kai killing Richard. Everyone gets
up in surprise but to their confusion, Zac admits
to killing him. He says that he had seen an alien
attach to Richard and had to kill him to kill
the alien. He then says that the alien might have
attached itself to someone else from the crew. The
naive crew believes him and starts suspecting each
other. With no evidence, they blame Peter
for carrying the alien and beat him to death.
After that, they collect all the sharp weapons
to fight the alien if it is still in the ship.
Zac’s team is skeptical but they are afraid to
speak against him. Meanwhile, in Chris’s team,
Sela suggests they get the weapons from the
secret compartment that Chris knows about. In the
following scene, we see Chris trying to open the
secret compartment behind the wall. But he gets
the passcode wrong making an alarm go off.
He runs away from the compartment and Zac’s team
arrives there. They get their hands on the weapons
and claim them as their own. Two of Chris’s
teammates decide to join Zac. Zac asks them for
the other’s location in turn for taking them in
and they happily tell him where the others are.
Now, his team approach Chris, Sela, and Phoebe
in the surveillance room. They barge inside and
hold Chris hostage. Before they can take him away,
Phoebe loses her control and yells at everyone to
come back to their senses. To everyone’s surprise,
an annoyed Zac shoots her dead.
Knowing that they are next,
Chris and Sela run away from the others. They
are soon followed by the group. After a while,
Zac finds them and chases them into the
airlock with a gun in his hand. Now,
with no way out, Chris quickly thinks of a plan.
He and Sela put on space suits and open the hatch.
So when Zac barges in, he is pulled into space.
He holds on tight to the doorframe and refuses
to move but at last, he is pushed into space.
Sela and Chris return to the rest of the group
who have become docile without their leader. The
scene changes to some days later when everything
has gone back to normal. After an election, Sela
is chosen as the new chief. She keeps a video
documentary as Richard did. In the documentary,
she reveals that they have decided not to take
the blue liquid again. But they will vote on
everything so no further conflicts arise.
A few weeks after the restoration of democracy
and peace, Sela finds out that she is pregnant
with Chris' child, and eventually gives birth to
a boy. Things seem to have changed back to normal
and everyone on the ship is happy. For the next
few decades, kids run around the ship playing and
learning about their duties while the elders take
care of them and teach them their true purpose.
And finally, after eighty-six years since
the launch, the ship is about to land on
the destination planet. The movie ends as
the old and the new generation watch them
getting closer to their new home.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.